cancer patients here in Northwest Syria
were already struggling to get treatment
following 12 years of Civil War then the
massive earthquake in February damaged
many hospitals
making their suffering even worse
five months on turkey has reopened its
doors for hundreds of Syrian cancer
patients to get proper treatment
the weight for treatment has been
agonizing I can barely find the words to
express how difficult it has been both
physically and emotionally we longed for
this chance to get the proper treatment
I wanted my wife to be with me in these
hard times but it is still not allowed
to have an escort for us
around 600 cancer patients were unable
to receive treatment following the
earthquake
some lost their lives while waiting
even though it's hard for patients to
enter without an escort as we are not
allowed to be with them in the Turkish
hospitals this decision has a
significant impact on these patients the
pain they endure every day is unbearable
and they have been struggling to survive
for over five months we still can't be
with our patients relatives and we hope
other steps will be taken in their favor
around 65 percent of the patients
traveling to Turkey are women and
children
the majority of them internally
displaced by the Civil War
through a coordination office these
patients entered turkey the patients are
being divided into groups today 45
patients have entered the Turkish
government has been receiving patients
for over 12 years however we still hope
for a long-term solution that would
allow these patients to get treatment
inside Syria
the absence of that solution means
people suffering will continue to grow
despite their container with hardships
syrians here said they would accept any
proposed solution that would make their
life easier but they also fear that
their resilience might end while they
wait for that to happen Syria
foreign